bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui contribuent semaine après
semaine à vous rendre de moins en moins
naïfs et donc de plus en plus en colère
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des taux d'intérêt de la hausse
des taux d'intérêts bonjour estelle
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous ravis de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
ses caches branle bas de combat dans les
banques centrales
que ce soit aux états unis ou dans la
zone euro une crainte de l'inflation a
poussé les investisseurs à vendre des
obligations
conséquence une forte remontée des taux
sur le marché
alors à quoi faut-il s'attendre quelles
conséquences est ce les prémices d'une
remontée économique on va en parler dans
cette émission et pour cela en deuxième
partie nous serons en liaison avec
pierre sabatier économiste et président
du cabinet prime view 1,62 % le
rendement à 10 ans sur les bons du
trésor américain est monté à son plus
haut de l'année le 5 mars dernier du
jamais vu depuis le 12 février 2020 le
taux à 30 ans lui était aussi en
progression aux alentours de 2 33%
une remontée qui avec en toile de fond
la crainte pour les marchés d'une
inflation incontrôlée ceto qui remonte
c'est notamment la conséquence aussi du
plan de sauvetage de l'économie
initié par joe biden et l'annoncent
d'une hausse de créations d'emplois
outre-atlantique
pour tout comprendre vous voyez cela
avec le tiroir cash d'antoine bassesse
[Musique]
cela faisait longtemps que les états
unis n'avaient pas connu une flambée des
taux d'intérêt aussi importante alors
pourquoi les rendements sur les
obligations d'état de long terme ont
atteint leur plus haut niveau en un an
pour être plus clair une obligation
d'état c'est un emprunt que fait un état
une créance qu'il contracte de la tête
et ses rendements d'obligations c'est ce
que ça rapporte de prêter à l'état en ce
moment prêter de l'argent à l'état
américain sur dix ou trente ans acheter
de la dette américaine
bah c'est plutôt une bonne affaire cela
traduit en fait une confiance qui après
l'énorme crise économique liée aux
mesures contre le coc u19 se retrouve
renforcé après l'élection de joe biden
et son méga giga gros plans de relance
1900 milliards de dollars rassurant non
pas pas tout à fait parce que cette
perspective d'une économie en bonne
santé d'une croissance retrouvée
participe également à une hausse de
l'inflation une augmentation globale et
durable des prix qui pourrait également
déstabiliser l'économie à son tour ça va
jamais bien quoi aux etats unis du côté
de la fed
on est en tout cas pas trop inquiet
affirmant que l'inflation ne dépassera
pas les 2 % leurs objectifs jusqu'en
et comme ce qui se passe aux states
touche forcément le monde entier à la
bce ont dit être sur le pied de guerre
avec pourtant déjà 1850 milliards
d'euros sorti du tiroir etc s'apprête à
augmenter le rendement
des versements de liquidités pour éviter
la méchante inflation harder better
faster stronger selon les mots d'un des
membres de son directoire
visiblement un fan de bonne musique
olivier une remontée à des taux en
flèche certes mais des taux qui reste
tout de même globalement historiquement
bas oui alors il faut relativiser quand
même les choses les taux ont remonté
c'est vrai maintenant ils étaient passés
pour la première fois dans l'histoire à
-2 1% et donc que vous êtes sur des taux
à 10 ans à 1,5 1,6 ce qui est tout à
fait acceptable mais qui ne sera pas
accepter longtemps par les banques
centrales
en fait moi je pense que cc c'est une
sorte d'avertissement plutôt que une
inquiétude réelle sur des perspectives
d'inflation c'est plutôt un
avertissement des marchés vis-à-vis de
la banque centrale de lui dire attention
même si l'économie repart
il n'est pas question que vous changiez
politique il n'est pas question que vous
arrêtiez la planche à billets et on va
vous donner un avertissement c'est à
dire qu'on fait monter les taux
d'intérêt
or on sait aujourd'hui que les banques
centrales ne peuvent pas se permettre et
les gouvernements non plus ne peuvent
pas se permettre
alors qu'ils vont émettre des centaines
de milliards de dollars ou d'euros pour
les banques la banque centrale
européenne avec un stock de dette
phénoménale
vous ne pouvez pas vous permettre une
remontée des taux donc vous aurez une
intervention très vite des banques
centrales pour remettre les taux en
dessous de 1 en ce qui concerne les
états unis et même en dessous de zéro en
ce qui concerne la banque centrale
européenne donc voilà on en fait après
il a fallu justifier cette hausse des
taux a posteriori en disant que c'était
des perspectives d'inflation
il est très peu probable qu'ils aient de
qui est de l'inflation pour la bonne et
simple raison qui a pas d'activité donc
comme vous n'avez pas d'activité c'est
difficile
d'avoir de l'inflation autre que la
petite hausse qu'on a vu récemment sur
le pétrole mais enfin qui reste je vous
rappelle quand même assez raisonnable et
qui
n'est pas du du tout à une reprise de
l'activité mais qui est due au
déversement de monnaie sur la tête des
investisseurs de tous bords merci
olivier on voit tout cela en détail dans
la deuxième partie de cette émission et
cette semaine dans ses cages nous sommes
en liaison avec pierre sabatier bonjour
pierre vous êtes économiste et président
du cabinet prime view merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci à vous bon je restais le bonjour
olivier bonjour auteurs alors pierre
sabatier tout d'abord selon vous
pourquoi ces taux d'intérêt remontent il
notamment aux états unis alors on l'a
expliqué dans le tiroir cache avec le
fameux plan de relance 1 de joe biden
mais est ce que c'est la seule cause
j'ai pas grand chose à ajouter par
rapport aux propos aux propos d'olivier
au début de votre émission
il a tout résumé alors on va prendre les
choses dans l'ordre si vous le souhaitez
donc les taux d'intérêt remontent
pourquoi a sorti un très bel exemple
d'ailleurs ce début d'année est vraiment
symptomatique du comportement des
investisseurs en général à savoir que
vous savez on n'a pas grand chose un
investisseur sa besoin de kwassa besoin
de raconter des histoires ou de se
raconter des histoires où trouver des
arguments pour séduire pour expliquer
pour paraître entre guillemets
intelligent et pouvoir alimenter gérer
ses clients et qu'est ce qui se passe
comme thématique qu'est ce que les
investisseurs jouent comme thématique
celui de la résurgence de l'inflation et
donc puisqu'il ya inflation
effectivement ce prétexte l'a amène les
taux d'intérêt à monter aux états unis
au premier chef et en europe parce que
l'europe n'étant pas autonome il faut
l'avouer n'est que suiveuse des états
unis bien les taux européens vente alors
même qu' il n'y a pas de sujet
d'inflation en europe ni croissance à
dire donc le sujet c'est déjà un
prétexte donc on s'est saisi de la
thématique inflation on va prendre
quelques secondes juste pour la démonter
très rapidement une forme de confusion
qui est fait
l'inflation c'est ça ne peut exister que
lorsque la demande augmente très
fortement ses cours à l'inflation ces
paniers un grand modèle mathématique
c'est simplement le temps nécessaire
lorsque la demande augmente pour que
l'outil de production soit proportionnée
pour la servir
donc à partir mans il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de la demande il n'y a
aucune raison et aucune possibilité pour
qu'il y ait une vraie inflation
l'ensemble de nos pays occidentaux c'est
le premier point le deuxième point c'est
que les gens vont vous dire oui mais
attendez regarder les matières premières
olivier évoqué le pétrole n'y a pas que
le pétrole y aller aussi loin
les prix des matières premières
industrielles les prix des matières
premières alimentaires
mais la réalité c'est que si le
phénomène d'augmentation des prix des
matières premières se poursuit
je pose la question qu'est ce que ça
avoir comme conséquences pour vous en
tant que ménages européens américains
plus de pouvoir d'achat au moins de
pouvoir d'achat moins de pouvoir d'achat
dire qu'un réalité l'augmentation des
prix des matières premières aujourd'hui
vient mettre en difficulté le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages qui n'est déjà pas
en grande forme dans vous comprenez que
la réaction cela des gens à terme dans
les mois à venir ça sera quoi
ce sera je dois payer plus cher mais
matières premières et de fait du coup je
n'ai - déjeuner - j'ai moins d'argent à
dépenser pour le reste donc en réalité
l'appréciation des prix des matières
premières les ramènera qu'elle-même au
tapis parce que la conséquence de cette
augmentation
c'est moins de pouvoir d'achat pour les
ménages - de marche pour les entreprises
- moins de capacité à investir donc
rendre au mont loin de croissance c'est
le premier point ça marche pour
l'inflation des prix des matières
premières ça marche aussi pour les taux
d'intérêt donc là aussi je vous pose la
question quand vous allez acheter votre
résidence principale
quel est votre premier réflexe la visite
est bien sûr une envie un besoin
assouvir mes l'autre premier réflexe
c'est quoi aller voir votre banque pour
savoir combien vous pouvez avoir pour
pouvoir acheter et donc faut comprendre
cela aussi l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt en réalité qu'est ce que c'est
elle même va ramener les taux d'intérêt
au tapis parce que ça veut dire quoi
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt c'est
à dire que les conditions de financement
de vos conditions de financement en tant
que ménages et en tant qu'entreprise se
dégrade et là je vous pose une dernière
question qui après j'arrête
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes en
capacité de supporter des conditions de
financement plus dégradés qu'aujourd'hui
la réponse est non les entreprises sont
en grande difficulté
on a des taux de défaillance qui ont
chuté en 2020 mais nous deux pour des
raisons totalement artificielle dire
qu'on a mis sous cloche notre économie
on a interdit de faire faillite
mais la réalité c'est que les
entreprises sont en difficulté les
marges ne se sont pas reconstituer le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages paris
artificiellement tout le monde nous
parle de l'époque de l'epan de l'épargné
mérité c'est parce que les chansons pas
idiot il ya eu un effet d'aubaine lié au
fait que l'état s'est mis en face me
bien content que la certitude qu'ils ont
de continuer à percevoir le revenu dans
les années à venir et pas et pas très
forte c'est pour ça que les gens aient
pas donc vous avez vraiment eu donc
hambourg les ménages sont pas capables
de supporter des conditions de
financement moins favorable et vous
verrez que si c'était le cas immédiate
et pris des mobiliers chuterait donc il
faut bien avoir en tête que la
thématique qui jouent et celle de
l'inflation et celle des taux d'intérêt
il ya une incompréhension totale de la
chose c'est que tout cela amène plus de
déflation et moins de croissance de
demain parce que l'économie s'est pas
autre chose que le comportement des gens
en tant que ménages ou entreprises et
vous avez compris que des taux d'intérêt
plus élevés des matières premières plus
élevés ça vous met en difficulté ça nous
met en difficulté et notre réaction
première c'est moins de consommation
moins d'investissement donc encore moins
de croissance
donc tout ça est une thématique joué par
les investisseurs mais vous verrez comme
d'habitude cette thématique elle
n'existait pas ya trois mois elle
n'existera plus dans trois mois olivier
on parlait donc des inquiétudes liées à
une possible inflation qu'en est-il de
celle liée à une hausse des taux
hypothécaires mois les taux
hypothécaires s'est principalement aux
états unis en europe
il y en a peu en france en tout cas il y
en a peu et
c'est ce que dit pierre à l'instant
c'est à dire que l'étau qui remonte vont
entraîner une hausse des taux
hypothécaires
or il faut se souvenir que c'est la
baisse
c'est toute la phase de baisse des taux
hypothécaires qui a soutenu la
croissance américaine pourquoi parce que
aux états unis quand les taux baissent
vous pouvez refinancer votre votre prêt
on vous prête à nouveau et le prêt qu'on
vous fait n'est pas attribuée à la
maison par exemple que vous avez financé
mais à ce que vous voulez donc vous le
consommer vous pouvez vous payer des
vacances avec etc
et ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
si vous avez une phase à nouveau de
hausse des taux hypothécaires
eh bien vous avez le phénomène inverse
c'est à dire que là pour le coup il faut
payer de plus en plus et donc vous ne
pouvez pas vous faire des prêts à la
consommation
aussi facilement je vous rappelle aussi
qu aux etats unis le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que les taux ne
peuvent pas monter ils ne peuvent pas
monter donc on va forcer en fait les
banques centrales à continuer à faire
tourner la planche à billets a continué
son quantitative easing pour faire
rebaisser l'étau pourquoi pas parce que
vous savez que vous avez les taux
d'intérêt par exemple qui vont peser sur
les dix 10 découverts bancaires que qu'à
chaque américain avec ses dix cartes
bancaires et donc vous les faites sauter
vous faites sauter les prêts étudiants
vous faites sauter les prêts sur les
voitures vous faites sauter le l'état
puisque l'état aujourd'hui est
surendetté autrement dit toute cette
histoire pour moi de hausse des taux
d'intérêt est simplement un
avertissement lancé par le marché aux
banques centrales qui ont commencé à
avoir des discours en disant que la
croissance allait être plus forte que
prévu que peut-être ça allait amener de
l'inflation qui n'existe pas comme l'a
dit pierre sauf pour les
les matières premières ou sauf pour
pouces qui et financiarisé c'est à dire
par exemple il me bâtir aussi et donc
qui bénéficient de cette manne
extraordinaire des banques centrales et
donc qui monte mais là aussi c'est un
coût pour le ménage l'immobilier c'est
un coût pour le ménage le les sens on
l'a bien vu avec les gilet jaune
c'est un coût pour les ménages donc vous
avez ce phénomène là qui est un
phénomène purement boursier purement
financier et pas du tout économique en
macroéconomie pour la bonne et simple
raison que 1 il n'y a pas d'activités
comme le disait pierre mais aussi parce
que l'utilisation des capacités est très
faible
vous avez aujourd'hui des boîtes qui se
tourne à 50% 60% donc qu'ils vont
répondre à la demande
immédiatement il y aura pas période
d'ajustement et ils vont répondre à la
demande immédiatement donc vous n'avez
pas d'inflation
en revanche vous avez un avertissement
des marchés qui disent vous êtes gentils
les banques centrales
vous continuez exactement comme avant
quoi qu'il arrive parce qu'on en a
besoin mais si on remarque une yourte
opposant vient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine la
remontée à des taux et pour cela nous
sommes en liaison avec pierre sabatier
économiste et président du cabinet
preview alors pierre sabatier juste
avant la coupure pub pub pardon olivier
évoqué cet avertissement des
investisseurs aux banques centrales
alors justement est la fed a tenté de
calmer le jeu les indicateurs
d'inflation vont monter mais pas
l'inflation sous jacente a déclaré par
exemple la présidente de la fed de
cleveland
est ce qu'on peut parler vous de bras de
fer entre elles les banques centrales et
les hedge funds alors olivier j'ai envie
de dire c'est bien une des rares fois où
finalement la réserve fédérale la banque
centrale américaine pensent comme nous
une certaine manière puisque en réalité
depuis de nombreuses semaines
elle ne cesse de dire ce qu'on vienne me
dire à savoir qu'il n'y a pas de
possibilité de résurgence d'inflation et
donc elle donne le message qu' il ne
faut pas compter sur une hausse des taux
d'intérêt et sur une politique monétaire
qui devait l'amener deviendrait plus
restrictives
c'est plutôt rare pour le pour le
souligner donc soulignons le après
est-ce que c'est un bras de fer oui
comme ça souvent été le cas
enfin je pour le coup pour avoir un
petit peu d'expérience dans le domaine
il faudra pas que les investisseurs
jouent trop longtemps hein parce que
c'est une grosse main comme on dit dans
la réserve fédérale américaine c'est
celle qui dispose de la machine un
premier des billets de banque dans la
cave et qui a la capacité en fait de la
faire fonctionner deux d'injecter des
billets directement dans l'économie ou
dans les marchés financiers sans aller
en prison si vous vous faites vous allez
en prison
donc pour faire attention quand même
faut pas jouer trop longtemps avec la
banque centrale mais je vais revenir sur
un autre sujet qui complète les propos
étaient qui avait co été posée jusqu'à
maintenant il faut vous aussi que les
investisseurs fassent attention parce
que la crise sanitaire nous a fait
oublier de là d'où venait il faut quand
même avoir en tête que le monde est
tendu devant détendu socialement en
france aux états unis partout il est
tendu donc il ya une forme de grogne
sociale
il faut faire attention parce que le
fait que les marchés financiers amènent
les prix des matières premières vers le
haut donc véritablement vers le haut le
pétrole mais pas que les matières
premières alimentaires faut faire
attention parce que là pour le coup
c'est là où lorsque les marchés
financiers
vienne 10
actuellement percuté la vie réelle des
gens à travers en fait ce qu'ils
consomment
en tant que tel donc les matières
premières alimentaires est bien là vous
pouvez avoir les catalyseurs parfait
pour que la grogne sociale oublier en
raison de la crise sanitaire depuis un
an
ressurgissent beaucoup plus vite que
prévu évidemment dans nos pays où on
était déjà très tendu socialement mais
aussi dans les pays émergents et puis
les plus pauvres qui sont les plus
susceptibles de pénaliser par
l'inflation des prix des matières
premières qui ne correspond pas en
réalité à une augmentation de demandes
comme l'évoqué olivier mais uniquement
c'est un dommage collatéral de
l'injection de liquidités de la part des
banques centrales et du monde d'hyper
liquidités dans laquelle on vit donc
faut faire attention parce que lorsqu'on
parle de matières premières ce n'est pas
un actif financier ce n'est pas qu'un
actif financier
c'est aussi un actif consommer et dans
un monde très tendu il faudrait pas que
ça dure trop longtemps icsa est trop
loin ou trop vite
donc en gros que les investisseurs
jouent trois cette thématique parce que
ça pourrait avoir des conséquences dont
on mesure aujourd'hui pas les effets
parce que lorsqu'on parle de tensions
sociales
on parle de rupture potentiel est là
pour le coup un vous verriez des
investisseurs qui ont finalement voulu
jouer une thématique et faire les malins
et qu'ils pourraient amener à une
rupture beaucoup plus difficile à
appréhender qu'il émettrait d'ailleurs
de même en difficulté donc sujet très
important c'est pas la question des taux
d'intérêt qui ne montrant pas les
banques centrales feront ce qu'il faut
c'est plutôt en fait la question sous
jacente que ça sous tend à savoir à
l'inflation
faut arrêter avec cette thématique là ou
alors ça entraînera ça pourrait
entraîner assez rapidement le débouclage
un certain nombre de deux ou l'aura de
la révélation plutôt d'un certain nombre
de tensions hérité de la décennie passée
un pas de la crise sanitaire avec les
sanitaires n'a fait qu exacerber une
situation qui était d'ores et déjà très
tendu avant christ alors messieurs on a
beaucoup parlé à des états unis un cap
sur l'europe à présent du côté de la
france le taux des obligations d'état
françaises à 10 ans est passé de -0 32 %
à - 0,1 fin février la france et plus
globalement l'europe olivier sont elles
dans la même situation que les états
unis exactement c'est à dire qu'alors on
va avec en plus le fait que
on cherche toujours la croissance nous
on ne l'a jamais trouvé
alors il paraît que bruno le maire l'a
trouvé à un moment puisqu'il nous a
annoncé 6 % croissance mais je crains
que malheureusement il est encore une
fois tort donc qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que on a de différent on a de différent
je vous dis un potentiel de croissance
qui est très faible qui est probablement
entre 0 et 1 quand c'est pas négatif
et puis de l'autre côté on a un
endettement qui est gigantesque
parce qu'on vous dit que là on a pris 20
points de de dettes de plus mais je vous
rappelle qu'on était largement déjà au
dessus de 100 % 1
alors après vous avez différentes
méthodes de calcul extra mais vous
pouvez vous dire que vous êtes très
probablement en france autour de 150% en
ayant quelque chose qui est plutôt
restrictif un je vous parle pas de
prendre les engagements de retraite etc
mais on est à 150 % si on est à 150 %
avec une une dette de
de 150% du pib' eh bien imaginez vous
que vous ne pouvez pas vous permettre
d'avoir des taux d'intérêt à 10 ans à 1%
par exemple parce que à ce moment là
vous dépassez systématiquement notre
croissance
donc vous êtes en fait en récession 1
si vous faites un moins un an et demi eh
bien vous êtes en récession de 0,5 en
gros c'est à peu près le le sujet donc
ça veut dire que aujourd'hui le l'état
ne peut pas se faire à l'état et les
banques centrales ne peuvent pas se
permettre
et c'est la même chose en italie c'est
la même chose en espagne ne peuvent pas
se permettre une remontée des taux donc
vous verrez bientôt très bientôt
la banque centrale est là hors de tout
sujet d'inflation ou autres parce que
évidemment s'il y en a pas aux états
unis on aura encore moins ici et bien
qui va se remettre à acheter pour aller
faire repartir les taux d'intérêt en
dessous de zéro exactement comme
souvenez-vous au japon à chaque fois que
c'est arrivé à chaque fois qu'on a
essayé fait que le patron de la banque
centrale monsieur pur oda a essayé de
ralentir ces programmes d'achat à chaque
fois les taux se sont tendus sont
repassés au dessus de zéro et avec la
dette qui là ils ont 250 on est en voie
d'aller vers 300 %
on devrait le sortir probablement à la
fin de cette année à 275
donc vous êtes très très haut et
évidemment ils ne peuvent pas se
permettre d'avoir des taux d'intérêts
positif et à chaque fois monsieur cureau
d'art revient à la télé pour nous
expliquer qu'il a fait une bonne blague
mais qu' il va continuer à acheter pour
maintenir les taux inférieur à 0,1
pierre savatier justement la bce s'est
dit déterminé à je cite combattre ce
phénomène de remontée des taux des
emprunts souverains
si les rendements obligataires devaient
grimper de manière incontrôlée elle ne
resterait pas ne restera pas les bras
croisés pardon concrètement quelle est
sa marge de manoeuvre
mais elle est totale intéressant alors
je rajouterais simplement un point et
qui valide le propos d'olivier sur
l'impossibilité de remonter les taux
pour les états mais pas que et je pense
que le pays d'ailleurs qui ne prouve
qu'ils supporteraient le moins la hausse
des taux c'est la france parce qu'il
faut pas oublier que les gens ne parlent
que de dette publique mais on a aussi
une dette privée cirque les ménages et
les entreprises sont endettés or la
france a été en fait suivi enfin une
trajectoire qui la plus dégradée en
europe depuis maintenant 20 ans il ya
vingt ans l'emploi en termes
d'endettement privé la france était
exemplaire au niveau européen il ya dix
ans elle était un peu moins qu'ils aient
une situation normale
aujourd'hui c'est la pire élève hier que
on parle beaucoup du tali on stigmatise
l'italie pour leur endettement public
mais si vous faites la somme de
l'endettement public et d'être en privé
la france c'est pareil
et donc vous parce que et donc vous
comprenez bien que nous nous avons
beaucoup de dettes publiques aujourd'hui
mais surtout maintenant beaucoup de
dettes privées et donc s'il est au monde
ça veut dire que vous allez fragiliser
encore plus les gens qui ont un stock de
dettes des mesures et les ménages
notamment pour des questions
immobilières donc immédiatement vous
voyez quelles conséquences ça pour avoir
sur le marché du mobilier sur les prêts
d'immobilier et les entreprises qui
elle-même affichent des niveaux
d'endettement très fort donc soyez
persuadé d'une chose c'est que il y à un
possibilité de remontée des taux sinon
tout explose et donc c'est donc ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point de
quelle marge de manoeuvre 10 post m mais
de toutes les marges de manoeuvre et
scriabine rocade est ce qu'il ya un
scénario que la bce doit par exemple à
tout prix éviter
la rondelle est au point or après
attention
et dire que dans son logiciel c'est la
remontée des taux si la banque centrale
veut éviter les dommages collatéraux v8
est en fait les ruptures
d'une certaine manière elle est dans
l'obligation de maintenir les taux
d'intérêt bas
après est ce que nos sociétés est ce que
le chemin qu'elle choisit et le bon ça
c'est un chemin non économiquement choix
politiques
est ce que le fait de maintenir
artificiellement les taux pendant très
bas pendant très longtemps ne va pas
empêcher la nature de faire son oeuvre à
savoir que les entreprises est ce que
faire cela c'est pas aussi entretenir
création de léthargie qui va nous
handicaper en fait pour reconstruire en
fait un modèle de société qui va plutôt
qui va mieux correspondre aux besoins
des gens qu'est-ce qui doit aussi
répondre aux tensions sociales qui ont
évoqué tout à l'heure donc il ya deux
dimensions et donc faut vraiment faire
la différence dans le logiciel de la
banque centrale dans l'objectif c'est
quoi ce éviter en gros les à-coups les
ruptures
elle n'a pas d'autre choix que maintenir
les taux bas après je pense qu'il faudra
qu'on se pose une question de société
donc c'est plutôt de l'ordre politique
est ce que pour herri est ce que le prix
à payer à terme pour éviter les ruptures
vaut le coup de soutenir tout le monde y
compris les morts-vivants est ce que le
fait de soutenir les morts-vivants ne
vient pas nous handicaper en fait nos
enfants les générations qui suivront
quant à leur capacité à disposer
d'argent pour investir pour construire
vraiment différent et ce sera le mois de
la fin merci beaucoup aux pierre
sabatier d'avoir été parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et président du cabinet prime
view olivier nous on continue avec les
questions cash au revoir pierre les
questions catch olivier avec la question
de rémy quel est le coût réel de
l'éolien et pourquoi dites vous que
c'est une arnaque
monsieur grandjean essayé de nous
expliquer la dernière fois que il
fallait mettre des gros ventilateur
partout et supprimer le nucléaire il
faut savoir que 1 aujourd'hui l'éolien
l'éolien en mai en mer par exemple vous
racheter l'électricité à 180 euros alors
que le cours moyen si vous voulez par
edf c'est 40 ça même été vain cette
année puisqu'on a consommé beaucoup
moins d'électricité mais en moyenne ces
donc on le paye presque cinq fois plus
ce qui est quand même délirant et c'est
nous qui le payons c'est nous les
consommateurs puisque à ce moment là ça
fait augmenter le prix de l'électricité
globalement on était à terre les
éoliennes à terre c'est 83 euros contre
40 toujours
dans le circuit normal si on veut
aujourd'hui faire du tout nucléaire
en gros ça va coûter 250 milliards je
prends les chiffres de monsieur
jancovici qui pourtant travailler avec
monsieur grandjean mais visiblement un
il a dû louper la dernière conférence de
monsieur jean que ici est donc en gros
c'est 250 milliards pour le nucléaire
ses 2500 à 5000 milliards pour faire des
rôles yens bon alors vous voyez qu'il ya
un moment où il faut quand même
réfléchir deux fois ne pas se lancer
dans n'importe quoi comme l'a fait
monsieur macron le l'éolien confond
subventionne tous les ans à hauteur de
plus de 10 milliards c'est c'est juste
grotesque c'est à c'est un support de
corruption c'est pour les élus
on a supprimé les recours qu'on avait
contre les éoliennes et aujourd'hui vous
n'avez plus que le conseil d'état vous
n'avez pas les tribunaux les instances
administratives avant face et c'est du
grand n'importe quoi c'est une arnaque
totale
c'est une arnaque écologique parce que
il ya des problèmes visiblement de santé
mais même si on ne parle pas de ça il ya
des problèmes avec la faune et ensuite
il ya des problèmes avec les terrains je
sais pas si vous savez mais il faut une
tonne de béton par m d'éoliennes une
éolienne ça fait entre 150 et 250 m donc
ça veut dire 250 tonnes de béton danse
dans le sol
vous imaginez bien que le béton on va
pas le retirer à la fin des éoliennes
on ne leur cycle aura pas et donc vous
avez des sols qui sont pourris pour pour
l'éternité donc vraiment c'est c'est une
vraie cochonneries ça ne sert à rien
vous avez une éolienne ça ne marche que
20 % à 20 % de rendement 20 % de
rendement c'est-à-dire rien quand il ya
trop de vent ça s'arrête quand il n'y a
pas assez de vent ça s'arrête aussi ça
ne sert strictement à rien donc il faut
arrêter avec cette histoire parce que
c'est juste pour s'en mettre plein les
poches
merci olivier c'est la fin de cette
émission
merci de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas de
poser toutes vos questions à olivier sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag rtk
champs se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro et on se quitte
avec votre mot de la fin olivier en
économie les choses ne sont pas toujours
celles qu'on essaie de vous faire croire